I don't like the fact that America is
bearing the brunt and the burden of
financing most of the war against Putin
and Ukraine I think we agree on that
part why isn't Europe why don't they
ever step up and defend their own
continent before they ask for U.S
involvement and why would Joe Biden veto
Poland given zielinski fighter jets to
actually fight to win the war after they
were invaded
well the more disturbing thing is that
on two occasions the Russians tried to
sign a peace agreement with zelinski you
trust Putin do I trust but no but that's
not I don't listen I I litigated over
500 lawsuits
all of them end up with or many of them
end up with settlements or one or the
other
and he never trusts the guy on the other
side you use language art and you use
the design of agreement so Ukraine to
appease Pete and Putin rather who I
think is evil they've already given up
Crimea it was annexed to what they now
they have to give up the dumbass area uh
you know they
Ukraine because of our
pushing the Ukraine into the war on two
occasions
let me let me answer your question
in 2019
France Germany and Russia all agreed to
the Minsk Accords
that year zielinski ran for president he
was a comedian in no political
experience why did he win because he won
ran on one issue signing the Minsk
Accords
as soon as he got in there Victoria
Newman in the White House told him he
couldn't do it
that Putin sends 40 000 troops in that's
not enough to conquer the country
clearly he wanted us to come to the
negotiation he wanted somebody to come
to a negotiating table so lensky came to
the negotiating table signed a new
agreement that was the Minsk Accords to
in 2022 and that would have allowed
dunpa's to stay and lugons to stay to
remain as part of of Ukraine
we sent Putin signed it
zielinski initialed in and Putin in good
faith began withdrawing troops from the
Ukraine
what happened we sent Boris Johnson over
there to torpedo it because we don't
want peace with we want the war with
Russia
whatever why are you blaming America's
role in this
and and look I I am Putin to me is an
evil murdering dictator Thug and when he
leaves this Earth nobody's going to miss
him let's be honest
um however I think that Europe has a
responsibility to protect their
continent and yet it always seems to
fall in the United States Joe Biden has
committed all these billions of dollars
that we can't afford and he's not
fighting the war to win the war I don't
believe in fighting Wars half-assed if
you're going to fight a war you go in
overwhelming Force you beat them you get
the hell out that's it and only if it's
provoked Putin did not need to invade in
a sovereign country in my view is
zelinski perfect nope I don't think he
is either I agree with you on that part
but America's role I think should be
dictated first by Europe and they've got
to defend their continent and they
haven't stepped up in my view no I mean
I don't think most of the European
countries wanted the war either
they we it's clear what happened which
is that you know from the beginning we
promised in 1992
the Russian leadership said we will move
this is what was Gorbachev
said when when the Soviet Union he was
getting ready to dismantle the Soviet
Union and he said we're going to allow
you we're going to withdraw 400 000
troops from East Germany
and we're going to allow you to reunite
Germany under NATO it was a hostile Army
that's a huge concession for them one
commitment that we want is what the
Russians said
is that you will not move NATO to the
east
James Baker who is then Secretary of
State under Bush famously promised we
will not move Nato one inch to the east
well since then we've moved in 1 000
miles in 14 countries now when we
started that plan in 1997
Bill Perry who was the Secretary of
Defense under Clinton said to the
Clinton Administration if you move NATO
to the east I'm resigning because you
are forcing the Russians to come to war
with us George Cannon was the most
important Diplomat in American history
the architect the containment policy
during World War II said the same thing
you do not need to make a a an enemy out
of Russia Russia should be treated the
way we won the Cold War it gets
accomplished let me ask you a question
China has been showing nothing but
hostility covid intellectual property
theft unfair Trade Practices they've
been confronting our Navy ships in
international waterways they've been
confronting our fighter jets in
international Airways they had the spy
drone go fly all around the country no
Joe didn't shoot it down they threatened
to shoot Hypersonic missiles at the U.S
they're threatening to take out Taiwan
and take over Taiwan they call it
reunification if your president would
you come to the defense of Taiwan or
Ally no no president no presidential
candidate with any prudence
would answer that question are are
our
policy our policy towards Taiwan is
strategic ambiguity and that makes a lot
of sense you don't want to project
you're an enemy what you're going to do
in a certain case we're embolden your
friends
to go to war thinking that you're going
to support them so that's been our
policy and assistance you see China as
our top geopolitical foe they're also
trying to undermine the U.S dollar you
do yeah and that's why
that's another reason
why the war in Ukraine is insane because
we have pushed China into
Donald Trump said
he could resolve the issue could you do
you think you can create a peace
agreement between Ukraine and Russia I
think we have to there's no joint
Russia's not going to lose this war
Russia can't afford this would be like
us
losing War to Mexico they're not they
are not going to lose the war go look at
what Russia did install in grad in order
to preserve its its territorial
Integrity Russia's been invaded three
times through Russia's been invaded
three times through the Ukraine the last
time
Hitler killed one out of every seven
Russians they're 400 miles from Moscow
we already have ages missile systems
within 12 minutes of Moscow
we wouldn't tolerate that if the
Russians did it in 1962 when they put
him in in Cuba my uncle was going to
invade if they if they I want to talk a
little bit about your background growing
up your uncle as president uh what
happened to him what happened to your
dad he was the Attorney General uh and
what you think about how what how those
things happen more with Robert F Kennedy
Jr as Hannity continues hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else